pencil like just bad spending habits
um so I'm going to say this in a
Christian perspective because I'm I was
raised as a Christian
so
um I never actually dated
uh
so this girl is the first time that I'm
going to a relationship and I'm still a
virgin and I'm a virgin because yes I'm
a virgin because I have to be a virgin
because in this day and age
I'm telling in this day and age I can't
be near any woman who like I'm not
saying this is this is like the general
of women who are like this but
um
they have their their expectations too
high and I I just don't want to mess
with with that and uh the other the
other thing I would say is
um
uh what I was about to say
yeah yeah so in terms of like spending
habits
um
I never had really to worry about that
but if if I let's in a hypothetical
um
uh scenario uh if she had this spending
habits of like going to designers shops
and buying jewelry here and then or like
you know like not not having a
um a goal in life in like
I wouldn't invest in this this and such
instead of she's going to invest in
something that it's like you said it's
not going to last that long so why would
I go through the hassle so I prefer to
be a version and wait to to be with a
woman that actually respects my decision
uh respects
um
that
um
being financially responsible it's it's
a it's a duty for for both yeah that's
it
all right um just to clarify you were
asking about if people have like a bad
spending if you've ever dated a girl
with bad spending habits and that was a
red flag oh yeah 100 and um there was
this one girl I was with and sorry I
remember this one day where she really
wanted to buy it uh she wanted me to buy
her Timberlands and and I I was working
a normal job and that I was making that
500 a month or whatever in it so I
couldn't really afford it you feel me
but she made such a big deal out of it
and from that moment on I realized
there's a major red flag you feel me I
was like 16 or whatever and it's like
the entitlement yeah it's not why are
you expecting that we both broke
how expensive Timberlands are now it's
like we have the same job yeah
here's the thing and ladies I don't
think many women these days understand
right
if you are a submissive sorry submissive
feminine woman who is friendly right and
pure
you have so much power and I think that
is the only time as a woman
you can kind of ask a man to be fully
like you know provide for you and all of
that because
the power of being feminine and being
submissive is a whole different level
you feel me like if I'm with a girl and
she wants to go out with her friends and
she's telling me Oh Yeah I'm want to
wear this dress I know it shows my
boobies and all of that but I just feel
confident in it fam that's a red flag
for me you feel me that you are my girl
why are you showing your boobies has
that happened to you it's happened to me
in the past but I can tell you about no
Mike all right now it's not been a
problem it's that it might trigger some
people but she asked me if it's okay for
her to wear ripped jeans you feel me
like and it's a whole different type of
relationship and I'm telling you man
them all you simps out there because I
gotta tell you there's a simple epidemic
right now and I think it's because
manama's all desperate right now man
them stop selling yourselves in it like
um don't let yourself do the matters for
these hoes because at the end of the day
there are some good women out there who
are going to respect you actually let me
not even lie to you you gotta fix on
yourself in it go to the gym make some
money and all of that in it but there
are some women out there but these
Western countries America London and all
that social media messed up all of that
you feel me like there's a lot of
entitled women out there I'm not trying
to get canceled or anything but I'm
gonna leave her at that
can I just add to your point I just
think you know when going into a
relationship it's a partnership there
has to be give and take reciprocated
energy reciprocated ways of thinking if
your man has Vision you want a
partnership okay okay you don't want to
punish equal partnership
I didn't say equal I said partnership
and you know sometimes it's in a
partnership business 50 partners are 50
50. no sometimes your relationship you
could be AE your partner could be 20 you
know sometimes it's 50 50 50 sometimes
it's 45 you know in reality social media
I agree has messed up a lot of things
for you guys there's a lot of pressure
on men to it to be financially basically
Invincible as I say Optimus Prime when
it comes to money yeah
yeah and you know ladies we do have to
look at the men that try for us the men
that really fight for us and push for us
you know at a simple day you know
there's a lot of symptoms in the comment
section what can I say they're
everywhere but it's an academic it's an
epidemic and with an epidemic there's
always a cure we have to look at the
cure for these problems we have to
represent
the the cure for the issue so we have to
have good relationships we have to
create those things to change the
environment that we live in
um and just to sorry to be all
philosophical about it but in reality
nothing's perfect so you know everybody
has their own experience and we should
you know enjoy our experience wait so
may I ask you would you think that's
what she's saying is very nice the
reality is very different yeah but you
know like I'm serious women live in
possibilities while women probabilities
so like women women that we live in like
this la la land where it's like
that sounds nice but like women get more
and more delusional we get fatter we get
less pure we get less of less of all the
things that men value men value men
vality value Purity they value Youth and
it's it's us it's not bad because
because because
women are a lot we're older than ever
before we're less pure I mean like every
guy praised for less than five bodies
how many [ __ ] got five bodies by the
time they're 31 which is the average age
of first marriage in the UK who's well
the reality is yeah let's we can be
pessimistic we can be negative you are
you are in control of your life right
negative looking at it's not negative
looking at facts this is just facts it's
brutal for men out here I'm trying but
it's always been brutal no no no no no
not like this not like this I'm telling
you no no no no
take this
like these days in 2022 right you as a
man if you look at your girl and she's
kind of putting a little bit away she's
going a bit chubby and all that yeah if
you even dare to try and say anything
and you yeah
it's a society in which we live we have
social media and I agree with you that
validates things like oh you're fat
phobic because you said to your girl are
you putting a bit of weight you know
what if my man tells me I'm pulling a
bit away you know I'm gonna say thank
you for letting me know because it's
about something
how does
doing my best to be
in a better perspective
back on all of this I if there are women
the most recent comment if anyone's
coming at you for having a job or saying
that you're broke because you work a
nine to five that person is quite
literally delusional the woman who like
that doesn't that doesn't even make
logical sense the girl who's saying you
need to spend how much are Timberlands
like 250 like on half your income at
what 16 years old to buy me Timberlands
like delusional like I cannot imagine
like even me I'm thinking back to my 16
year old self I would quite literally
it's like like my 16 year old boyfriend
if he like I couldn't have met like I
just don't understand where these women
are you can't make those generalizations
okay I'll give you some data and then
I'll give you something from this
conversation okay what what percent of
the time do you think women swipe right
on dating apps 50 75 women swipe right
yeah right so yes like oh like I
okay
not often five five to fifteen percent
of the time fifteen is like the high end
it's it's typically closer to five yeah
because there's different apps what
percent of the time do you think men
swipe right on dating apps well they
swipe I mean this is what they've told
me they literally just swipe right on
everyone and then they just make their
decision afterwards right but okay okay
okay but think think about this why why
did they do that so they can see their
options okay right because women's
standards are ridiculously high yeah
that's why they have to do that women
swipe right or men swipe right 45 of the
time so so so that's on top of that okay
second of all and and I know you're
saying like where are these women but
but you're that woman because you wanna
no and and wait wait and respect you
seem very nice but again you're asking
for a guy that makes more than you which
is 80 to wait wait oh my God 80 to 100
000 a year that's a top ten fifteen
percent guy so so and then the quest
question is are you top 10 15 girl not
money-wise but by the things that men
value and so even you you might not ask
them to spend that money on you but you
still want someone that's in the top 10
15 percent and so women we have these
crazy high standards that men can't meet
uh okay can I respond yeah go ahead okay
so I understand what you're saying like
we do have extremely hyper like high
expectations values oh so sorry we do
okay sorry is this good hello okay so
yeah we do have these we do have high
expectations and I and I understand that
I am that woman as well like I want
someone who can make I I would just
prefer to make to have to be dating
someone that makes at least as much
money as I make because if I wanna have
a child oh if I want to take some time
off work I don't want the child I just I
would feel more comfortable with both
parties we're bringing in around the
same amount of resources into the into
the family that's just what I would
prefer but we'll see what happens
I understand the argument that you're
making that okay we do have high
standards however this is like I kind of
going back to Kevin Samuels which I
literally like made that man rest in
peace but like I got Kevin cannot could
not could never could do not like maybe
he rest in peace but like not a fan not
a fan me my girlfriends like would drag
this man he did bring up some good
points he did bring up some good points
like like a lot of the things that come
in like Samuels like this whole
narrative is like women have unrealistic
standards then they're not willing to
like make themselves or like not make
themselves but better themselves to like
so that they're attracted to those types
of guys so a woman who doesn't go to the
gym that often a woman that doesn't have
you know specific attributes that the
typical man would like isn't even trying
to even more maybe more of herself but
like highlight those things that she has
like talking about like being more
feminine and things like that I
understand that line of logic and that's
probably the only thing from Kevin
Samuels whole thing that I will get in
line with because I do think that's true
you need to stay fit you need to make
sure that you're doing your job to like
make yourself better it sounds like you
agree with him that
that I'm coming from when I say that
women we have too high of Standards I
mean again I'm not arguing with you but
I do it's it's like average women too
yeah I mean I I mean that that is sad
like when you really think about it and
like when you're talking about these
these statistics like I think you take
my taking myself out of it like thinking
about like the 50 auroras hundreds of
there's hundreds of like thousands of
auroras out there that are kind of my
demographic right and I you know when
you think about the numbers that is kind
of you know it is scary and sad and I
just I think Kevin's point is like we
can want what we want that's fine it's
it's it's okay but like if if a a guy
that wasn't making any money wanted
Beyonce we would kind of laugh but like
when as women we can come forward and
say I want a top 10 guy and nobody's
gonna I just nobody's gonna look at you
twice and it's you know I think like
would I prefer a guy that makes more
than me yeah but do I think I'm gonna
get one probably not well I mean I mean
but it's also not a and like I don't
remember who was saying and I apologize
but like there's so much more that goes
into like having a partner than like
like uniquely the money and I know what
Kevin said is like what Min values like
femininity if they're submissive like
sexual abuse that type of stuff women we
value money being a provider strength
like these heteronormative like like
very clear gender lines can I ask you
another question how tall does he have
to be so
this conversation all the time I'm five
six okay I was like you seem a little
tall yeah I'm five six I so this is my
thing my dad is six eight okay so I have
I have my mom is five two my mom is five
yeah my mom is five too I'm five six I
have two my sister my other sister's 60.
I have like tall jeans so I can afford
like my kids will be like again the
whole natural selection thing that's fun
yeah so I need a height give me a height
a minimum minimum the thing is no no
please
objectively I would prefer like my ideal
man is six two so ideally but I've liked
guys that were my height before okay so
so your minimum your minimum is five six
like or let's just be honest five five
seven five eight yeah okay so five eight
is acceptable but you're not gonna be
super excited until unless he's six two
like excited about what like super
attracted to him super like you really
want six two I mean I
yeah
okay do you want to be attracted to him
I would hope so okay so so let's take
ten percent of men make more than you
yes now half of them are below five
eight so that's that's five percent of
men okay now now you're at five percent
now you want to be attracted to him
let's say half of them are ugly
that's two percent of guys
and and you have to compete and you
might have to share
because because think about it if you if
you find him attractive and he has all
the things you want that means other
women want him that means every girl in
this room probably wants him that
doesn't mean you have to share it means
you might it means but this is options
that still doesn't mean that you have
okay okay okay and I'll give you an
example so my dad is a top one percent
earner half a percent I grew up in these
families or in in that family my dad
didn't cheat but my mom got him when he
was broke so if you want to get him on
that level he's he's probably gonna
cheat you didn't help build like you
didn't help him get there like this like
what it's not that I want to think I
don't okay why don't you say something
like this it's just because okay but
like people like whether or not
someone's gonna cheat on their partner
has nothing to do with the amount of
money but their character so but okay if
if someone I just think men are men and
it's easy to say like let's take Tiger
Woods it's easy to say like why you know
why did Tiger Woods cheat but most men
don't have a a Bus full of models
waiting for them and I think most men
even even good great men with character
if they are in a position where women
are are standing at the Finish Line
begging to have sex with them they might
do it and that's where a lot of the the
top two percent of men might be this is
what I always say if you dated NBA
player basketball player I don't I don't
really feel bad you get cheated on like
I I don't I mean again I'm cheating but
like I will always go back to this when
it comes to cheating regardless like
there's someone there's a five six man
that will cheat on someone who's
unattractive there's a six four like
beautiful man like true it has nothing
to do with like how many women that are
I'm in my opinion everyone someone's
Unfaithful in their relationship has
everything to do with their character
and has everything to do with their
choices has nothing to do with like
there's some men that like okay I can't
but some men are more likely to do it so
but this is this is my point so now you
want a top two percent guy that also
won't cheat on you this is a unicorn
and so even you you're a nice woman
right you you're Pleasant right and I
don't think you're asking these men to
be spend crazy amounts of money on you
but you're still a normal girl that's
that has that's asking for a top one
percent man and this is this is kind of
like encompassing the problem okay and
again I understand when you break it
down in that way yes like I can
understand like your line of logic but
again I'm gonna push back and say like
all the same thing is inverse like for
my partner wherever he is in this world
like all those things like I'm going to
fit all those all those like boxes like
that are against him as well like
there's someone like I and again like
maybe I am being delusional like and
that's fine because like I'm happy to be
delusional and most women are yeah I'm
happy to be delusional but like I have
there's no doubt in my mind that I'm
going to be married and there's no doubt
in my mind that my partner won't you
know like I believe and I pray that like
I'll have it like so healthy so here's
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible